شكرا عبد القادر طبعا البارز اليوم هو
مزيد من التوغل للقوات الاسرائيليه وايضا
تجديد الحمله العسكريه على المناطق
الجنوبيه لا سما في خان يونس نحللها مع
اللواء فيز دويري الخبير العسكري
واستراتيجي مرحبا بك لواء دويري محمود الك
يطلعنا اولا على ابرز المواجهات ستبدا من
الجنوب من خان يونس نعم نعم جلال هنا
نشاهد هذه الخارطه لكامل قطاع غزه ايضا
خان يونس المعارك محتد ما هناك وهي مركز
الثقل في العمليات لكن يبدو ان ال لا يوجد
تقدم كبير وتراجع كبير في هذه المنطقه
خاصه اذا ما توجهنا دعونا نشاهد هذا اللون
الاصفر هي لحركات مناورات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كما كنا نذكر سابقا الجيش
الاسرائيلي كان دوما يحاول التقدم من
الشرق الى الغرب في مختلف القطاعات في
مختلف حركات المناوره لكن الضغط التكتيكي
يبدو انه كان اليوم هنا من الاتجاه الغربي
في محاولات التقدم من مستشفى الامل اضافه
الى مقر الصناعه الذي تم قصفه اليوم وهنا
سنشاهد هذا هو مقر الصناعه التابع لونر
وهو يقع في هذه النقطه تحديدا اي بالتالي
هناك قصف له رغم انه ياوي نازحين بالتالي
لا يمكن فهم تماما الاستراتيجيه العسكريه
في محاوله لقصف مقر للنازحين خاصه وانه
من المعروف انه مقر للاونروا ويوجد به
العلامات كما ذكر مراسلونا يرفع الاعلام
او الاشارات الاونر لكن الضغط العسكري
ياتي هنا باتجاه مستشفى الامل من الغرب حي
الامل محاولات تقدم على مستوى اقل من على
مستوى الشوارع تحديدا لكن ما تزال
المقاومه تستطيع الصد والرد هنا كان هناك
الانباء عن استهداف بقذائف الياسين في هذه
المنطقه في منطقه غرب غزه غرب خانيونس
بشكل عام استهداف
لدبابات الميركافا والاليات الاخرى
ل جيش الاحتلال من اللافت ايضا ذكر هذه
المعلومه هذه هي الانش الالويه التي تنشط
في كامل قطاع غزه نتحدث عن الشمال الوسط
والجنوب هذه هي مناطق العمليات المختلفه
هنا في الشمال
في مدينه غزه وايضا بيت لاهيه وبيت حانون
هنالك ثلاثه الويه اثنان من المشاه هم
ولواء مدرع اضافه الى كتيبه تعمل من لواء
جفعاتي هناك بالتالي هنا يتم عمليات
تكتيكيه مختلفه في محاوله لضبط عمليات
المناوره في الوسط تبدو العمليات كذلك من
ثلاثه الويه تحتوي على لواء للمظليين
للمدرعات والمشاه ويبدو ان مهمتها تقتصر
على او تحاول فصل العمليات ما بين الشمال
والجنوب واللافت هنا وحسب المعهد الدراسات
الحروب هنا نتحدث هناك سبعه الويه تعمل في
الجنوب هذا هو مر مركز ثقل العمليات هنا
سنلاحظ سنلاحظ سبعه الويه ثلاث مدرعات
لواءه لواء مظليين ولواء مشا اضافه الى
لواء من القوات الخاصه هناك لواء انسحب ما
بين فتره ال من يناير وال 21 من يناير هو
هذا اللواء هذه هي الالويه المنسحبه من
كامل قطاع غزه لكن هذا اللواء هو اللواء
900 هو الذي انسحب حسب معهد دراسات الحروب
وكانت كان سبب هذا الانسحاب بحسب ما ذكر
المعهد من مصادر اسرائيليه بانه يتم بغرض
اعاده التدريب واعاده تقييم
العمليات ولكن هذا سنتركه دوما للتحليل
العسكري معكما جلال واللواء فايز ك اشار
اليه سابقا رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
هاليفي عن هذا الانسحاب اللواء الدويري
واضح بان كما اشار محمود لهذا العدد
الكبير من الالويه التي تنشط في الجنوب
ودائما حسب الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول النشاط
فوق الارض وتحتها التركيز على خان يونس في
في هذه المرحله ما الذي رصدته في الساعات
الماضيه من معارك ومواجهات وايضا القصف
الاسرائيلي بالمناسبه سيناريو محاصره
المستشفيات في جنوب قطاع غزه مثيل الان
لما حصل في الشمال
ال
جزئيات ما طبق في غزه يحاول تطبيقه خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالمنظومه الصحيه وقارن بين
الامل وناصر وبين الشفاء والاندونيسي وغير
ذلك فبالتالي هذه المقاربه واضحه جدا كذلك
المقاربه الاخرى من حيث التشابه العام مع
مع اختلاف التفاصيل هو محاوله التطويق في
غزه تم التطويق وتحدثنا بها كثيرا واصبحت
معروفه للقاسي والداني ولكنها لم تستطع ان
تحقق الاهداف التي من اجلها شنت العمليه
في منطقه الوسط كذلك حاول التطويق ولكن
اخفق فلجا الى تجزئه المخيمات ومح تطويق
المخيمات كمخيم منفصله حتى حدثت ما حدثت
يوم الامس فاعادته الاو
مجددا في الجنوب كما تحدث تم سحب احد
الالويه ولا يسحب اللواء في العمليات الا
لاسباب جوهريه اهم هذه الاسباب انه انهك
الحق به خسائر تزيد عن 40% واؤكد هذا هو
الاستاندرد الامريكي وهو اسرائيل تطبقه
وعندما تحدثنا عن لواء جولاني وتحدثت عن
40% انه فقد من قدرته القتاليه
وجدت من زاد على هذا الرقم احد الخبراء
الاستراتيجيين البريطانيين واحنن معجبين
كل غرب برنجي يعني زي ما بيقولوها
فبالتالي هو قال 45% انا قلت 40% بناء على
الاستاندرد العالمي وهو الاستاندرد
الامريكي فهذا اللواء لن يسحب الا بعد ان
يتدنى اداء القتالي يصبح عب على الوحدات
الاخرى وبالتالي يصبح عاجزا اصلا عن
الدفاع عن نفسه يتم سحبه ولكن ابقي على
سبعه
الويه تحاول ان تعمل عمليه الاحاطه حتى
هذه اللحظه لم تستطع ان تطوق لماذا هي
الان من المنطقه الشرقيه تطوق محافظه
خانيونس لانه شريط ال مع السياج هم دخلوا
هذه المنطقه وباع ماق متباينه عملوا بها
اختراقات من الطرف الثلث الشمالي ومن
الثلث الجنوبي بعد اطراف عبسان وعبس
وبالتالي استطاعوا الوصول الى طريق صلاح
الدين علما بان طريق الصلاح الدين في
الجزئيه الاخيره من خانيونس تكون على بعد
مئات الامتار وليس على ذلك العمق الكبير
وا الان مدينه خان يونس كمدينه تتعرض
لهجوم ثلاثي الابعاد الهجوم الاقوى
والاعنف ياتي من الغرب القوات التي عملت
الاحاطه في بدايه العمليه قبل اكثر من شهر
عندما اخذت
من من الاقصى الشمال ومن كوس فيم الى
القراره الى المطاحن الى الحمد الى
المواصي الى جوش قطيف ومن ثم بدات بالدخول
واستطاعت ان تدخل والى مناطق محدده الان
بدا هذا
الهجوم جبهه الهجوم تتسع وبدا القصف يمهد
كما تم في قصف المركز في هذا اليوم بقي
الجانب الجانب الشمالي من من اجل تسييل
عمليه
اختراق لانه الان اذا تحدثنا عن مدينه غزه
سيكون هناك جهدين رئيسيات و جهد ثانوي
الجهد الرئيسي الاول الذي ذكرته قادم من
الغرب تم بدفع جهد جديد من منطقه القراره
باتجاه المطاحن مع طريق صلاح الدين وصولا
الى بدايات خانيونس والهجوم الثالث وهو
الثانوي والذي تعثر قبل عده ايام في منتصف
الاسبوع الماضي الذي وصل الى قيزان النجار
وعمل تواصلا مع منطقه البوليتكنيك
وبالتالي الان هناك ثلاثه اتجاهات للهجوم
هجوم رئيسي هجوم رئيسي
وهجوم ثانوي قد يقول البعض هجوم رئيسي
هجوم مساند هجوم ثانوي بغض النظر عن
المسميات لكن المنطقه الشرقيه هي منطقه
ملتهبه باستثناء مدينه خزاعه تخضع لعمليات
قصف لماذا لانه دخل تم ارسال احد الالويه
اخفق كليا في الخول وبالتالي الان لا نعرف
لم تاتي اي صور من خزاعه ولا اي انتصارات
من خزاعه فقد تكون عمل بها كما عمل في بيت
حانون لواء دويري لدينا سرايا القدس بثت
صور قالت انها لقصف مشترك مع كتائب القسام
بقذائف الهاون لخط امداد وسير اليات الجيش
الاسرائيلي شرق جباليه شمال قطاع قز انت
تتابعه للمره الاولى سنتابع الفيديو بعدها
نعلق
عليه
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر وله
الحمد والله
الحم هذا هون 60
باستثناء الان الصين بدات تصنع وامريكا
وبعض الدول المتقدمه تكنولوجيا بدات تدخل
التكنولوجيا الحديثه في توظيف الصاروخ
وبعض صار بعدها يوجه عبر الجي بي اس لكن
الهاون التقليدي هو عباره عن قاعده تسمى
الصينيه يركب عليها ماسوره الاطلاق ولها
منصب امامي وعليه جهاز تضبيط بال ملذات
قديما ماخوذ من ايام البريطانيين ويرمي
رمايه منطقه ورمايه قوسيه وفي بعض الحالات
كان يطلق عليه يرمي من فوق الذروات او من
فوق القمم لانه لاحظ طريقه التوجيه
فالمحرك لهذه الط لهذه القذيفه لا يتماثل
مع محرك المدفعيه 155 والان تريبل س يقال
لها فبالتالي هذا يستخدم للرمايه من خلف
التلال من خلف كذا على كما قلنا اهداف
منطقه بمساحه ملعب كره القدم ضد اهداف بغض
النظر ما هي لكن تاثيره على الاليات
المقاتله كنمر وال المركا فه سيكون محدود
لكن التاثير الرئيسي انه يمنع الافراد من
الخروج من هذه وبالتالي قد يوظف اقول هنا
قد يوظف لمهمه لاحقه المهمه اللاحقه تكون
انه الان اشغال قوات العدو المدرعه منعهم
من الخروج والمراقبه منع من الص وود من
البرج والمراقبه البصريه سيعتمد على
المراقبه التكنولوجيه الان قد يسمح لاعضاء
الفرق المقاتله الذئاب المنفرده ان تتسلل
وتوظف اسلحتها القصيره لتنير الدبابه
المعلومات حول هذا الفيديو تقول بانه
استهداف لسير وخط امداد خط امداد ما اهميه
قطع او محاولات قطع خط امداد الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعني قبل بالاسبوع الماضي الم
يتم انزال 16 طن بالجو لماذا امداد مقطوعه
هذه القوات يعني نابليون يقول الجيوش تزحف
على
بطونها عبارته الشهيره الجيوش تزحف على
بطونها ماذا يعني هي لا لا يعني لا ناخذ
الكلام بحرفيته وكانه يقول الذيل الاداري
يطلق عليه الذيل الاداري الذيل الاداري
يكافئ الذيل العملياتي لضمان استمرار
المعركه فالان عندما نتحدث عن عمليات
الامداد ناخذ في بعدي في ابعادها الثلاث
الابعاد الطبيه الابعاد اللوجستيه الابعاد
العمليات واي منها يتعطل او ينفقد تتوقف
الوحدات عن القتال فبالتالي رغم انه
المسافه كانت ما بين 16 الى 17 م اجبرت
قوات العدو على الانزال المظلي وهذا يدل
على
هشاشه ما يطلق عليها السيطره طيب نعرض
فيديو الان نشره جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لما يقول بانها عمليه في قطاع غزه نترك لك
التعليق اللواء الدويري انت دائما تشير
انه لا يوجد لطرف لطرف اخر دائما دائما
الجيش الاسرائيلي يصور نفسه
يطلق يصور جانب من المعركه يعني لم يعني
صوره تتماثل مع صور القسام حتى يعني دعنا
نصفهم شيئا ماض اكثر هو وا القسام عندما
او السرا تطلق قذائف الهاون نحن نلاحظ
عمليه الاطلاق ولم ولاحظ عمليه السقوط
للقذيفة
حياته ساجده هذا الفيديو الشهير الفيديو
الشهير وشاهدنا بالامس فيديو عندما دخلوا
الى المبنى وكان هناك اطلاق نار وكان حدث
اصابتين من في جنود الاحتلال فقط هؤ هذه
الفيديوهات التي انا شاهدت انها تمثل
معركه حقيقيه وواقعيه ما عدا ذلك هو جانب
واحد يعني بكلمه واحده اكثر هو استعراضي
من من فقط هي رساله للداخل نحن نقاتل
ابنائكم في الجبه شكرا شكرا اللواء فيز
وير الخبير العسكري واستراتيجي